pasemos a las ciencias sociales.
Y en particular, quiero que pensemos dónde está el potencial para la humanidad
y dónde estamos ahora.
Y si lo piensan, hay una gran brecha
entre donde creemos que podríamos estar y donde estamos,
y eso se da en todas las áreas.
Así que déjenme que les pregunte:
¿Cuántos de Uds. en el último mes han comido más de lo debido?
Solo en general. Bien.
¿Cuántos de Uds. en el último mes
han hecho menos ejercicio del que creen que deberían?
¿Y para cuántos de Uds. que han levantado las manos dos veces
es la mayor cantidad de ejercicio que han hecho hoy?
(Risas)
¿Cuántos de Uds. han enviado mensajes de texto mientras conducían?
Estamos siendo honestos. Probemos su honestidad.
¿Cuántas personas aquí en el último mes
no siempre se han lavado las manos al salir del baño?
(Risas)
Un poco menos honesto.
Es interesante cómo estamos dispuestos a admitir enviar mensajes y conducir
pero no el de no lavarnos las manos, eso es difícil.
(Risas)
Podemos seguir y seguir.
El problema, el tema es que hay muchas cosas
que sabemos sobre lo que podemos hacer.
Podríamos ser muy diferentes, pero actuamos de manera muy diferente.
Y cuando pensamos cómo cerrar esa brecha,
la respuesta habitual es: "Solo díselo a la gente".
Por ejemplo, diga a la gente que enviar mensajes y conducir es peligroso.
¿Saben que es peligroso? Deberían dejar de hacerlo.
Dices a la gente que algo es peligroso y se detendrán.
Enviar mensajes de texto y conducir es un ejemplo.
Otro ejemplo muy triste es que en EE. UU.
gastamos entre USD 780 millones al año
en lo llamado "educación financiera".
¿Y qué obtenemos como consecuencia de eso?
Recientemente un estudio analizó toda la investigación que se ha realizado
sobre educación financiera: lo que se llama un metanálisis.
Y lo que encontraron es que cuando dices a la gente,
que les enseñas educación financiera,
ellos aprenden y recuerdan.
¿Pero la gente lo lleva a cabo? No tanto.
La mejora es de un 3 o 4 %,
inmediatamente después del curso,
y luego baja
Y al final,
la mejora es de un 0,1 %,
no cero, sino tan humanamente cercano a cero como sea posible.
(Risas)
Esa es la triste noticia.
La triste noticia es que dar información a la gente
no es una buena receta para cambiar el comportamiento.
¿Qué es?
Las ciencias sociales han avanzado mucho,
y la idea básica es que, si queremos cambiar el comportamiento,
tenemos que cambiar el entorno.
La forma correcta no es cambiar a las personas, sino el entorno,
Y quiero presentar un modelo muy simple de cómo pensarlo:
Pensar en el cambio de comportamiento
de la misma manera que pensamos en enviar un cohete al espacio.
Cuando pensamos en enviar un cohete al espacio,
queremos hacer dos cosas principales.
Primero, reducir la fricción.
Queremos que el cohete tenga la menor fricción posible,
así que hay que hacerlo lo más aerodinámico posible.
Y segundo, queremos cargar la mayor cantidad de combustible posible,
para dar la mayor cantidad de motivación y energía para hacer su tarea.
Y para el cambio de comportamiento es lo mismo.
Entonces, primero hablemos de la fricción.
En este caso de estudio en particular
les hablaré sobre una farmacia en línea.
Imagina, vas al médico.
Tienes una enfermedad de larga duración.
Tu médico te receta un medicamento,
te registras en esta farmacia en línea
y recibes el medicamento por correo cada 90 días.
Cada 90 días, medicación, medicación, medicación.
Y esta farmacia en línea quiere hacer cambiar a las personas
de medicamentos de marca a medicamentos genéricos.
Entonces envían cartas a las personas diciendo:
"Por favor, cambie a genéricos.
Ahorrará dinero, ahorraremos dinero, su empleador ahorrará dinero".
¿Y qué hace la gente?
Nada.
Entonces prueban todo tipo de cosas y no pasa nada.
Entonces, durante un año, ofrecen a la gente una oferta increíble.
Le envían una carta a la gente que dice:
"Si cambia a genéricos ahora, los tendrá gratis durante todo un año".
Gratis por todo un año. ¡Asombroso!
¿Qué porcentaje de personas creen que cambió?
Menos del 10 %.
En este punto, se presentan a mi oficina.
Y vienen a quejarse.
¿Por qué me eligieron?
Escribí un par de artículos sobre el "encanto de la libertad".
En esos artículos, mostramos que, si se reduce el precio de algo
digamos, de 10 centavos a 1 centavo, no pasa mucho.
Lo reducen de 1 centavo a 0, la gente se emociona.
(Risas)
Y dijeron: "leemos estos documentos 'gratis', los dimos 'gratis'.
No funciona como esperábamos.
¿Que está pasando?"
Y dije: "Tal vez es una cuestión de fricción".
Y preguntaron: "¿Qué quieres decir?"
Y dije: "La gente comienza con la marca.
No pueden hacer nada y termina consumiendo la marca.
Para pasar a genérico, tienen que elegir genérico en lugar de marca,
pero también tienen que hacer algo.
Tienen que contestar la carta".
Así que esto es lo que llamamos un "diseño confuso".
Dos cosas suceden al mismo tiempo.
Es marca versus genérico,
y no hacer nada versus hacer algo.
Y dije: "¿Por qué no lo cambiamos?
¿Por qué no enviamos una carta a la gente y decimos:
"Te estamos cambiando a genéricos. No necesitas hacer nada.
Si desea seguir recibiendo la marca, responda la carta".
(Risas)
¿Sí?
¿Qué creen qué pasó?
Pues, abogados y más abogados.
(Risas)
Resulta que esto es ilegal.
Por cierto, para la lluvia de ideas y la creatividad,
hacer cosas ilegales e inmorales está bien,
siempre y cuando sea solo en la fase de lluvia de ideas.
(Risas)
Pero esta era la pureza de la idea
porque el diseño inicial era que la marca tenía el beneficio de la no acción.
En mi diseño ilegal e inmoral, el genérico tenía el beneficio de no actuar.
Pero acordaron darle a la gente una intersección en T:
enviar una carta a la gente diciendo:
"Si no responde esta carta
nos veremos obligados a suspender sus medicamentos.
Pero cuando responda la carta, puede elegir la marca a este precio,
o el genérico a este precio".
Ahora la gente tenía que actuar.
Estaban en igualdad de condiciones. ¿Sí?
No era que uno tuviera el beneficio de no actuar.
¿Qué porcentaje creen que cambió?
La gran mayoría cambió.
Y esto, ¿qué nos muestra?
¿A la gente nos gustan los genéricos o las marcas?
Odiamos responder cartas.
(Risas)
Esta es la historia de la fricción: las cosas pequeñas realmente importan.
Y la fricción trata de analizar el comportamiento deseado
preguntando: ¿Dónde tenemos demasiada fricción
frenamos a la gente de actuar en consecuencia?
Y cada vez que uno ve que el comportamiento deseado
y el comportamiento fácil no están alineados,
significa que queremos intentar realinearlos.
Esa es la primera parte. Hablamos de fricción.
Ahora hablemos de motivación.
En este estudio particular,
intentábamos reunir gente muy pobre de un barrio pobre llamado Kibera en Kenia
para que ahorraran algo de dinero para el tiempo de vacas flacas.
¿Saben? Si eres muy, muy pobre, no tienes dinero extra,
vives con una mano delante y otra atrás,
y de vez en cuando pasan cosas malas.
Y cuando sucede algo malo, no tienes nada a qué recurrir y lo pides prestado.
Un préstamo en Kibera puede significar hasta un 10 % de interés por semana.
Y luego, por supuesto, es realmente difícil salir de eso.
Vives con una mano delante y otra atrás, pasa algo malo,
pides prestado el dinero y entonces las cosas empeoran y empeoran.
Queríamos que la gente ahorrara un poco de dinero para las malas rachas.
Y pensamos en cuál podría ser la motivación,
y qué combustible necesitábamos agregar.
Y probamos todo tipo de cosas.
A algunas personas, les enviamos SMS una vez a la semana diciéndoles:
"Por favor, intente ahorrar 100 chelines -- alrededor de un dólar -- esta semana".
A algunas personas, enviamos un SMS como si viniera de sus hijos.
Y decía: "Hola mamá, hola papá, soy Joey"
-- cualquiera que fuese el nombre del niño --
"Intenta ahorrar 100 chelines esta semana para el futuro de nuestra familia".
¿Sí? Soy judío, un poco de culpa siempre funciona.
(Risas)
Algunas personas ahorraron el 10 %.
"Ahorre hasta cien chelines, le daremos un 10 %".
Algunas personas ahorraron el 20 %
Algunas personas también ahorraron el 10 % y 20 %
pero lo lograron por aversión a la pérdida.
¿Qué es la aversión a la pérdida?
La aversión a la pérdida es que odiamos más la idea de perder
que lo que disfrutamos ganar.
Piensen en alguien que está en una situación del 10 %
y juega 40 chelines.
Juega 40 chelines, le damos 4 más,
dice muchas gracias.
Esa persona renunció a 6.
Podría haber obtenido 6 más si hubiera jugado 100,
pero no lo ve.
Y creamos lo que llamamos pre-juego.
Pusimos los 10 chelines al comienzo de la semana.
Dijimos: "¡Te está esperando!"
Y luego, si alguien pone 40, decimos: "Pones 40,
dejamos 4 y recuperamos 6".
Entonces, en ambos casos, pre-juego o post-juego,
la persona recupera el 10 %.
Pero en el pre-juego
ve que el dinero que no jugó sale de su cuenta.
Entonces teníamos los SMS, los SMS de los hijos, 10 %, 20 %,
pre-juego, post-juego.
Y teníamos una condición más.
Era una moneda de este tamaño,
con 24 números escritos en ella.
Y les pedimos que pusieran la moneda en algún lugar de su cabaña,
y que cada semana con un cuchillo rascaran el número de esa semana
semana 1, 2, 3, 4,
que rascaran un signo negativo, si no ahorraron
y que rascaran arriba y abajo, si sí ahorraron.
Ahora, piensen:
¿Cuál de esos métodos creen que funcionó mejor?
El SMS, el SMS de los hijos, el 10 %, el 20 %,
al principio de la semana, el fin de semana o la moneda?
Les diré lo que piensa la gente promedio.
Hemos hecho estos estudios de predicción,
tanto en EE. UU. como en Kenia.
La gente piensa que el 20 % tendrá mucha aceptación,
el 10 % menos,
y el resto no tendrá nada de aceptación:
hijos, moneda, nada de eso importa.
La gente piensa que la aversión a la pérdida tendrá un pequeño efecto.
Pero ¿qué pasó realmente?
Enviar un SMS recordatorio una vez por semana
ayuda mucho.
¡Buenas noticias!
Este programa duró 6 meses. La gente olvida. Recordar a la gente es genial.
El 10 % al final de la semana ayudó un poco más.
Los incentivos financieros funcionan.
El 20 % al final de la semana, al igual que el 10 %, no genera diferencia.
El 10 % al comienzo de la semana
ayuda un poco más.
La aversión a la pérdida funciona.
El 20 % al comienzo de la semana,
al igual que el 10 % al comienzo de la semana, no genera diferencia.
Y el SMS de los hijos fue igual de efectivo
que el 20 % más aversión a la pérdida.
Lo cual es asombroso, ¿verdad?
Es sorprendente lo motivadores que fueron los mensajes de los hijos.
Y una conclusión es que no usamos a los hijos lo suficiente.
(Risas)
Y, por supuesto, no me refiero en un sentido de trabajo infantil.
Pero si piensan en los padres y sus hijos,
somos lo mejor que podemos para nuestros hijos,
y pensamos en el futuro.
Y creo que deberíamos pensar
cómo usar esa increíble fuente de motivación
para que los padres se comporten de mejor manera.
Pero la gran sorpresa de este estudio fue la moneda.
La moneda básicamente duplicó los ahorros en comparación con todo lo demás.
Y ahora la pregunta es: ¿por qué? ¿De qué trataba la moneda?
Les diré cómo empecé a pensar en la moneda
y luego volveremos a eso.
Cuando investigo, digamos, mientras me compro un café,
no necesito ir a ningún lado, me puedo sentar en mi oficina.
He comprado suficiente café. Sé cómo funciona.
Estoy familiarizado con los detalles.
Cuando investigas en algunos de los lugares más pobres del mundo,
tienes que ir allí y ver qué pasa
y hacerte una idea de cómo funciona el sistema.
Y en ese día en particular,
estaba en un lugar llamado Soweto en Sudáfrica,
sentado en un lugar que vendía seguros funerarios.
¿Saben que en EE. UU. la gente gasta grandes sumas de dinero en bodas?
En Sudáfrica en funerales.
Las personas gastan hasta uno o dos años de ingresos en funerales.
Y sentado en este lugar
-- por cierto, antes de juzgar a los sudafricanos de irracionales por esto,
solo quiero recordarles
que gastar mucho dinero en funerales en comparación con bodas,
al menos uno logra la certeza que solo será uno --
(Risas)
Bien, entonces sentado en este lugar que vendía seguros funerarios,
este tipo entra con su hijo, su hijo tiene unos 12 años,
y compra un seguro funerario por una semana.
Cubrirá el 90 % de sus gastos funerarios
solo si muere en los próximos siete días.
¿Sí? Estas son personas muy pobres, compran pequeñas cantidades de seguro
y una pequeña cantidad de jabón y tal.
Y él consigue ese certificado,
y de una manera muy ceremoniosa, se lo da a su hijo.
Y mientras se lo da a su hijo, pienso para mí, ¿por qué tanta ceremonia?
¿Qué está haciendo este padre?
Ahora, piense en el sostén de la familia que decide ese día en particular
invertir algo de dinero en seguros o ahorros.
¿Qué va a ver la familia esta noche?
Van a ver menos.
¿Sí? En ese nivel de pobreza, habrá menos comida, menos queroseno, menos agua...
algo menos esa noche.
Y lo que hacía su padre y lo que nuestra moneda trataba de hacer
es decir, sí, hay menos comida en la mesa,
pero hay otra actividad.
Lo que sucedió es que hay muchas actividades económicas
buenas e importantes, como ahorros y seguros, que son invisibles.
Y ahora la pregunta es: ¿cómo las hacemos visibles?
Así que volvamos a nuestro modelo de cohete.
Tenemos que, antes de nada, mirar el sistema
y ver dónde hay pequeñas cosas que podemos arreglar, con fricción,
¿Dónde podemos eliminar la fricción?
Y luego, lo siguiente es pensar ampliamente sobre el sistema,
y preguntarnos: ¿Qué otras motivaciones podemos aportar?
Y ese es un ejercicio mucho más difícil,
y no siempre sabemos qué funcionaría mejor.
¿Será dinero? ¿Será la aversión a la pérdida?
¿Será algo visible?
No lo sabemos y tenemos que probar cosas diferentes.
También tenemos que darnos cuenta de que nuestra intuición a veces nos engaña.
No siempre sabemos necesariamente qué funcionaría mejor.
Entonces, si pensamos en esta brecha
entre donde podríamos estar y donde estamos,
es realmente triste ver esta brecha y pensar en ello.
Pero la buena noticia es que hay muchas cosas que podemos hacer.
Algunos de los cambios son fáciles, algunos son más complejos.
Pero si atacamos cada problema directamente,
no solo proporcionando más información a las personas,
sino tratando de cambiar la fricción
y agregando motivación,
Creo que podemos...
¿Podemos cerrar la brecha? No.
¿Pero podemos mejorar mucho? Absolutamente que sí.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)